but my duty must be done even alone for
the children I knew press their souls on
REE and Horus two of the only children
to have ever escaped the clutches of
oldrich the maneater now undead and
unhindered they stride willingly back
into his grasp
oh hello how do you do I am an array of
astora on kindled like you and you two
in search of the Lords of cinder we seek
the Cathedral home of the Grimm Aldridge
we may go our separate ways now but we
are both seekers of Lords the next time
we cross paths one may find the other in
a time of need oh yes Horace he's not
very talkative but don't think ill of
him he's an upstanding kind-hearted
night
fine part of this grueling journey
please stop this you've gone Hollow have
you then I shall put you to rest Horace
join me and may the flames watch over us
Oh Horace why don't leave me not you not
like the others
Oh Horace horse
everyone forgive me I was weak on my own
from this we learn of honorees fear fear
that those by her side will die you can
imagine this fear would have been born
from her childhood in the Cathedral as
the children alongside her were
sacrificed
so if Horus lives then he remains a
source of strength to her for a little
longer on Ruiz blue Sentinel without his
help I would have cursed this onerous
duty long ago at the end of the road of
sacrifices sits the Cathedral of the
deep and deep within the cathedral is
the monumental coffin of oldrich the
man-eater oh right and rocker cleric
only he developed a habit of devouring
men
he ate so many that he bloated like a
drowned pink then softened into sludge
so they stuck him in the Cathedral of
the deep back then the Cathedral of the
deep was a holy place full of
god-fearing deacons devoted to the way
of white and to the linking of the fire
and it was imperative that the fire be
linked for that's the way it's always
been at the end of every cycle a
powerful being must be sacrificed to
keep the flame lit the cathedral a place
of sacrifice may well have been designed
for this so it came to be that a saint
named Aldridge was sacrificed and they
made him a lord of cinder no further
true but from lightened such as a lord
his word the fire doesn't care if you've
consumed men women children if that's
made you more powerful than all the
better so oldrich this terrible
gluttonous saint must have been powerful
indeed the Deacons tended to the flame
and slowly they were corrupted by the
evil they were tending to eventually of
course even this fire faded the world
darkened at this time no one stepped
forward to link the fire so the world
continued to darken till the fire linked
bell tolled Lords of old rose from their
graves
oldrich among them brought back to link
the fire again these Lords came back
clinging to life and they will off to
let it go so they refused to sit their
Thrones once more and with this refusal
came the unhindered ashen undead each
tired to a lord secret to yawn the
Giants friend Hawkwood to the legion he
abandoned and Unruh to Aldridge whose
clutches she escaped as a child
after her and Horace escaped the
Cathedral of the deep they went on to do
great things
unrefined herself drawn to the land of
astora as it was being destroyed by the
spirit of the evil eye with nothing but
a dull blade and luck she defeated the
creature Horace killed a corrupt
executioner he stripped the executioner
of his armor and gave it a new legacy he
would become a blue Sentinel protecting
the weak from rosaria's fingers these
red phantoms who take the tongues of
those they kill in battle I'd say that
explains the voice and death could not
keep either of them with Horace undead
and unreal and 'old they rejoin forces
and fight their way back into this
horrific home they left as children to
fight a familiar evil that rises again
and alas honoré and Horace find
themselves staring into an empty coffin
and well pleased to see you safe we
reach the Cathedral of the deep but
Aldrich's coffin was empty the man-eater
must have left for his true home the
little doll in the empty coffin told me
wherever you go the moon still sets an
aerosol wherever you may be
aerosol is your home a pilgrim told me
that the city lies beyond Ferren keep
and so becomes our destination
you
oh hello how very fortunate have you
seen my companion Horace to my shame I
was snared by a trap and we've become
separated I've not been able to find him
since
if you tell honoree where he is then
Henry will go to find him full of fear
that she might have to confront Aldrich
this childhood horror alone but a hollow
remembers no one so it is better that
she go on alone oh where have you run
off to
if you abandoned me know what horrible
thought we find Unruh next in the Church
of yashka she's alone she's tired you
can see this in her stance she's losing
faith and she's so close to Aldridge who
hides behind the pontiff who called him
home oh I thought it might be you good
to see you I never managed to find
Horace but my duty must be done even
alone as a nun kinking flawed seeker for
the children I knew bless their souls we
will have our reasons don't we and
kindled are born from the ash of undead
who tried to link the fire in a past age
and kindled can go hollow - just as
Horace did reverting to that hollow
state devoid of a soul even Lourdes can
go hollow but it is men who are branded
with the dark sign that leaks their
humanity their soul from them here if
you do nothing then Anri will go Hollow
but what if there is more to the dark
sign - hollowing
we pilgrims of lund or are keenly aware
that those branded by the dark sign
possess something quite special a
pilgrim told me that the city lies
beyond Ferren keep no spell of a maid
named Anne Marie she is hollow and will
join the in wedlock a fellow of mine
guides her at this moment when the time
is right thou mayst make thy salutations
for what Lord taketh no spouse to become
a lord of Hallows is to embrace the
curse that mankind was given you make it
your strength not your weakness you
embrace a new identity but you must take
the sigils of others in the name of that
goal and as you rest the flame from its
mantle on rhe kneels in the background
her purpose forgotten in exchange for
yours would you abandon your humanity
for this
[Music]
you'll Bree ah you are brave indeed to
face your duty alone I would do well to
learn from you may the flames guide your
way but neither of you are alone
together you kill the pontiff and
together you face oldrich ah I thought
it might be you then I'm afraid Horace
no this only bolsters my resolve please
lend me your strength
help me vanquish oldrich the man-eating
fiend
yes we did it
I owe this to you thank you truly
Horace we've done it we really have no
spell the name angry of astora
the brave girl left this as things now
heed this little warning from this
little Lord seat not the girl she knows
her fate what will become of her
upon her duties end she would not wish
to follow her her duty fulfilled honor
II will hollow in one of two places if
you told her where Horace hollowed but
killed him to protect her then on
replaces one last prism stone and
hollows alongside her companion her Duty
fulfilled
if Anri never found horace then she
hollows in front of these tiny graves
may be built for horace or for the
children they once knew so how will your
story end
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you